hey youtubers it's Charlie so we're
getting closer to an actual thor
ragnarok teaser with footage from the
movie we're going to see one of the
infinity gems probably the soul gem in
that movie so I'm gonna explain where
all the gems are they're six gems what
they all do in how that's going to
figure into infinity war so real quick
rundown on the location in like which
each of the gems are in this gauntlet
here there's six gems total so I'll
explain where they are in the MCU and
then I'll explain like what each of them
specifically does in the comics the
movies tend to simplify things a little
bit but first was the tesseract that's
the space gem that enabled people as you
could guess to travel anywhere they want
to they can be omnipresent you can
basically warp yourself all over the
universe the gem itself is the one that
sits on top of the fist here so it kind
of looks like this orangish glow if you
remember the mind gem which is like the
next one is actually yellow even though
it's in that blue thing during the first
Avengers movie they tend to switch
things I think they just want the gems
to look different because the colors in
the MCU is different from the gems
colors in the comics so it gets a little
confusing but it just enhances people's
psionic powers so you have the mind gem
like way over here on his thumb and
here's where things get really
interesting because the gems when used
together boost the abilities of the user
so like when you use the mind gem with
the power gem it grants you simultaneous
access to all the mines in the galaxy so
you get the idea even if you only have
two gems it's still a really big deal
because when the abilities work together
they kind of recontextualize things and
it starts to get really crazy so the
mind gem as we note is in visions for
head until Thanos rips it out we have
the reality gem which is the aether from
Thor the dark world it's got some very
mystical sounding abilities it grants
the user the ability to make things
happen that normally wouldn't be
scientifically possible so it basically
turns you into a genie where you could
be like you know what I'm kind of hungry
so I want an entire planet made out of
ice cream boom you snap your fingers
planet made of ice cream currently the
reality gem as far as we know is still
with the collector that's where they
took it at the end of Thor the dark
world we didn't see it leave his
presence during our
the galaxy even though he also during
that movie came into possession of the
power gem which is purple which at the
end of that movie went with the Nova
Corps so that's still with the Nova
Corps but that basically gives the user
control over all forms of energy that
exists or will exist and it also boosts
the abilities of all the other gems so
those are the four gems that we've seen
so far leaving the time gem which is
green which is in dr. Strange's eye of
agamotto give some control over all time
very simple idea in the soul gem which
only leaves this blue gem right here so
I'm guessing it's going to be blue
wherever it shows up in the movies which
I know is weird because a lot of people
feel like Heimdall might have the soul
gem because he's so powerful he has the
innate ability to see across the entire
universe he could spot anybody anywhere
but I think a lot of that has to do with
the technology in the Rainbow Bridge and
the other abilities that are enhanced by
Asgardian technology and stuff that's
given to him by Odin but it's totally
possible that he's the guardian of one
of the gems but there is the rumor that
he might die during Thor Ragnarok
because it arose elba isn't like
superhot on playing the character
because he's not a big thing in the
movies so it does seem like he's gonna
have a big blaze of glory moment and
Ragnarok whether it's against Thanos or
against the forces of Ragnarok but you
seen the gems you've seen this teaser
that they dropped I think was like last
year maybe even the year before last
year this teaser has been around for a
while with him in the gauntlet it was
just meant to make you poop your pants a
little bit
but it's going to be a lot more
complicated than that it's just going
around grabbing the gems sticking them
in the gauntlet then going to the next
gem we have the idea of the ancients the
elders of the universe the Eternals
basically like the more cosmic beings of
the universe the immortals there's a
rumor that they're going to appear
during guardians of the galaxy and we'll
explain you know some of the grander
threat in the design of the universe
itself like the universe has a will
there are things that are even bigger
than that us that are really upset at
the idea that the annos wants to destroy
everything already either anybody would
want to destroy it they want to protect
life in the universe so I'm expecting
the MCU version of that to be like a
little bit simpler than the comics so
whoever ends of appearing I think will
be like
movies version of the Living Tribunal
which is basically like the soul like
the entirety of the multiverse given
form in like a living consciousness so
that is some grand cosmic so it's
going to take a while to work up to that
so I wouldn't expect any name drops The
Living Tribunal any time soon we're just
going to find the next gems meet these
new characters like Doctor Strange and
then like once we get to Thor Ragnarok
will seethe annos start actually going
for the gems rumor is is that we'll
actually hear that owes explain his plan
just a little bit to Loki in the movie
like Loki makes the bargain because he
doesn't want to be erased from existence
once Thanos as you know starts to
remodel the universe using the gauntlet
but if you've read the infinity war
comic really like any of the Infinity
Gauntlet comics with Thanos
it's going to be a little bit different
from that it'll be way simpler probably
wave your characters but because fans
like the next movie that Thanos is
appearing in like in a big way is going
to be Thor Ragnarok that's the movie
that will explain the stakes so they're
going into infinity war people who
haven't read the comics will have some
context for what it all means like why
is it so important that we stop him from
assembling this gauntlet why is it that
he wants to do that so if you've read
the comics you already know all this
stuff but you have to remember that a
lot of people that will go see these
movies have absolutely no idea what's
going on they just have like the Thor
thing going on during that funny trailer
where he's like who is the purple man in
the chair like that's one of the reasons
why that trailer was so funny because
most people like who haven't read the
comics are actually saying that exact
same thing like who is vanos who is the
purple man what are the infinity gems
which is why it's so brilliant I would
expect more funny videos like this when
we get closer to infinity war just as a
way for Marvel to like explain to people
what's going on
without having to spend like 20 minutes
during the movies to stop and explain
things but here's my big question for
you guys do you think that Heimdall is
the guardian of one of the infinity gems
or do you think we'll see the soul gem
in Thor Ragnarok but it'll be somewhere
else
that Thor and Hulk will find on their
big cosmic roadtrip like it won't be on
Asgard with Heimdall I know a lot of
people are like what about the Midgard
serpent but technically he's supposed to
be locked in the center of the earth in
is where the aether was I don't think
that's also where the soul gem would be
like they wouldn't be right next to each
other but here's a really cool deep
infinity gems cut from the comics so
there's this gestalt entity basically
like the living form of all the infinity
gems called nemesis that soul is inside
ego the Living Planet Peter Quill's
father which we're going to meet during
guardians of the galaxy so in the comics
when ego is reunited with the other gems
it reforms nemesis which is like this
really terrible terrible thing that you
don't want to happen so James Gunn said
that there's not going to be any
infinity gems in guardians of the galaxy
- and we're not going to see a nose so I
don't think that they're going to do
that from the comics but it's just a
nice deep cut Easter Egg like if ego
were to come into possession of all the
infinity gems instead of forming the
Infinity Gauntlet
you would actually reform the sentient
entity that is all of the gems together
so you're reforming a God who is the
gauntlet or you're wielding the power of
a god when you wear the gauntlet like
Thanos so just something that's really
cool but I don't expect the movies to
address it giveaway time though
congratulations to this week's giveaway
Nick Carrera you win a copy of the
Captain America Civil War blu-ray be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there's a new round that
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video
blu-rays droppin really soon so there'll
be a whole bunch more Marvel DC this
week so get hype it's going to be
awesome
you'll start seeing a lot more infinity
gem related stuff as the movies get on
in the next year while you guys wait for
my next video you can click here to
watch that funny thor ragnarok trailer
again and you can click here to watch
the Civil War bloopers again thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you